[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be diving into some
common misconceptions about the
Wizarding World uncovering aspects of
The Wizarding universe that even
die-hard fans sometimes get wrong if you
fancy yourself a Harry Potter expert
then sit back relax and see if any of
these Harry Potter misconceptions apply
to you let's get into it Hogwarts
letters arrive on 11th birthdays you
might believe that receiving your
Hogwarts acceptance letter is magically
synchronized to your 11th birthday for a
truly Unforgettable celebration however
vax revealed that Hogwarts sent letters
to all students at the same time every
year regardless of their birth date this
momentous occasion typically occurs a
couple of weeks before the start of the
new term giving all students from
wondrous Wizards to marvelous
mugglebones ample time to prepare for
their magical education
ravenclaw's symbol is a raven it's easy
to assume that Rowena ravenclaw's house
with its raven-like name would adopt the
Raven as its symbol however the emblem
representing this esteemed house is
actually the noble Eagle a bird renowned
for its Keen intelligence and piercing
Vision the eagle perfectly embodies The
house's core values of wit wisdom and
the pursuit of knowledge Ravenclaw
colors aren't silver and blue the
Beloved Harry Potter movies brought JK
Rowling's magical Universe to life but
certain artistic Liberties led to a few
minor inconsistencies one such deviation
is the portrayal of Ravenclaw house
colors instead of the evocative
combination of bronze and blue described
in the books the films present a silver
and blue Motif though visually
captivating it doesn't capture the true
essence of ravenclaw's values all
slytherins are evil the Slytherin house
is often misunderstood and to an extent
vilified due to the actions of Infamous
dark Wizards hailing from its ranks
however we must remember the sage words
of Albus Dumbledore that it is our
choices that shape us far more than our
abilities or affiliations as illustrated
by Heroes like Severus Snape and regulus
black Slytherin is home to more
complexities and moral discrepancies
than a blanket statement of evil can
encompass
a phoenix can only be owned by
Dumbledore Forks the Regal and loyal
Phoenix is undoubtedly linked with the
great Albus Dumbledore yet the concept
of Phoenix's being exclusive to The
Dumbledore lineage is false in the
whiner Wizarding World these fiery and
mysterious creatures can form strong
connections with all sorts of
individuals who appreciate and honor
their Majestic and magical traits
phoenixes are rare but not singularly
aligned for instance the magical
Menagerie in Diagon Alley is known to
occasionally stock these magnificent
fiery Birds invisibility cloaks are
unique to Harry Harry's invisibility
cloak one of the three Fable Deathly
Hallows is undoubtedly special however
it should be noted that other
invisibility cloaks do exist in the
Wizarding World they just don't possess
the same rare Properties or history as
Harry's durmstrang and bulbatore are
single gender schools while the movies
illustrate Durham Strang and as single
gender schools the novels clarified that
each School comprises a diverse array of
magical talents regardless of gender
this misconception stems from visual
limitations within the film adaptations
voices don't change with Polyjuice
Potion the Harry Potter films
inaccurately depict that when using
polyju's potion The Voice remains
unchanged save for the exceptional
portrayal of Barty Crouch Jr
in contrast JK Rowling's Source material
makes it clear that when an individual
consumes Polyjuice Potion they adopt the
target's appearance as well as their
voice making for a more comprehensive
and immersive transformation
Hogwarts is located in England Hogwarts
Castle the mighty educational Fortress
we all dream of attending is often
associated with England this however is
not the case in reality this esteemed
Academy of Witchcraft and Wizardry
resides in the rugged breathtaking
region of the Scottish Highlands A
fitting location for the secrecy and
Grandeur that the Castle's Legacy
demands only good wizards can cast a
Patronus and though evil wizards casting
a Patronus is exceedingly rare it's not
impossible the ability to cast a
Patronus though strongly aligned with
those who are morally good does not
entirely exclude those with a more evil
temperament the best example of this is
Dolores Umbridge who is able to conjure
a cat Patronus demonstrating that light
magic in some instances can be harnessed
by people with dark Hearts this
highlights the strength of Will and
determination as instrumental factors in
harnessing power
Hogwarts is the only School of magic
while Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry holds a special place in our
magical Hearts it isn't the only magical
School in existence many other academies
of magic can be found across the globe
each with its unique history practices
and cultures prominent examples include
dermstrang logaru bobato
brushu kodov storyits and more time
Turners can change the past time
traveling is a tantalizing plot device
sprinkled throughout fiction but in the
Wizarding World of Harry Potter time
Turners don't behave as we might expect
instead these magical artifacts operate
under novikov's self-consistency
principle which posits the changes made
in the past will already have been taken
into account historically the evidence
Harry Potter and the Prisoner of
azkaban's finale where Harry saves his
younger self from dementos using a
Patronus despite not knowing that he'd
already done so Avada Kedavra can't be
blocked the killing curse of Vada
cadaver is arguably the most infamous
dark spell in The Wizarding Community
famously known for being unblockable
however we mustn't forget the
extraordinary Power of Love which
safeguarded Harry from this very curse
when the magic of love the strongest and
most ancient bond that transcends mere
incantations teamed up with the
legendary Lily Potter sacrifice not even
the deadliest curse could try him no one
can affirate or disapparate in Hogwarts
Apparition and disapparition within
Hogwarts is typically impossible due to
powerful protective enchantments
enveloping the castle nonetheless
exceptions to exist Alba stumbledore and
his extraordinary magical expertise
managed to lift these enchantments
temporarily allowing himself and Harry
to operate during their quest for the
horcrux in a seaside cave
Muggles and wizards are entirely
separate though the international
statute of Wizarding secrecy actively
Endeavors to maintain a strict divide
between the Wizarding and muggle worlds
it it would be an exaggeration to claim
total isolation after all muggleborn
witches and wizards carry the magical
bloodline forward and muggle authorities
such as the British prime minister are
aware of Magic's existence hence while
preserving their unique identities these
two Realms occasionally coexist and
intersect most Wizards can fly without a
broom the notion that most Wizards can
perform unsupported flight is misleading
in reality only a handful most notably
Voldemort and suffer a Snape demonstrate
this exceptional ability for most other
witches and wizards the trusty
broomstick Remains the preferred mode to
take to the skies prophecies don't
always come true while the prophecy
concerning the boy who lived played a
pivotal role in shaping the events of
the Harry Potter series it's crucial to
recognize that prophecies don't
necessarily come true as Albus
Dumbledore's sagely emphasized and
prophecy is sent to be more complex than
surface level interpretations would
dictate which is why it's unwise to
consider them Absolute Ironclad
determinants of Destiny choosing
yourself as a Secret Keeper the fidelius
charm is a powerful spell that conceals
a secret within a designated secret
Keeper's Soul ensuring that only this
individual can disclose it many fans
have asserted that embedding the secret
within the same person it protects is
impossible however Canon would suggest
otherwise for example we know that bill
Weasley is the secret keeper for Shell
Cottage and Arthur Weasley is the secret
keeper for the burrow assuming that
these are their places of residence this
proves that a person who lives in the
house being protected can also be
eligible to Bear its Secret Keeper the
only ambiguity here is that the fidelius
charm placed on shell Cottage in the
borough was designed to protect the home
itself in the case of say the voter
family this may not have worked as it
was the family that needed to be the
subject of the charm and not necessarily
the home Voldemort's Soul was split
seven times not eight Voldemort
initially created 6 cruxes by splitting
his soul into various objects however he
inadvertently turned Harry into Hawk
rugs and also pertained a fragment of
his soul in his own body this
technically means that Voldemort's Soul
was split into eight parts not seven as
believed by some the number of times his
soul was split and the total pieces of
his soul are figures that are often
conflated James Potter was a chaser not
a Seeker contrary to common fan
perception and even some indications in
both the movies and the books JK Rowling
has revealed that James Potter was
actually a chaser and not a Seeker on
the Hogwarts Quidditch team this may
surprise fans But ultimately the author
has final Authority on her characters
and that's it for this video were any of
these news to you be honest let me know
down in the comment section below until
next time remember differences of habit
and language are nothing at all if our
aims are identical and our hearts are
open